how many like useless skills have you
ever learned in your life
it's just my entire life
my entire life is a list of useful
skills every video game ever every video
game ever i think one day what counts as
a useful skill i don't know i'd like
like okay okay so like the reason i
learned pen spinning is because i fidget
like i i guess we just started but the
reason i learned pen spinning is because
i just really like to fidget as you guys
know yeah so i thought to myself
if i fidget all the time might as well
make it look cool you know and that's
literally the reason i learned how to do
the pen spin thing
i just did it because i was bored in
class
otherwise i'd probably just like start
chewing on the pen or something right i
don't know i was like i was definitely
that kid what about like the people who
liked uh felix does this with the knives
yeah i wanna i wanna you can't really
bring a knife to school can't you yeah
how do you even hate each other how do
you learn and get into that and then
start doing it way too scared to try
it's it's not about learning getting
into that because there's so many
youtube channels that you know teach
that kind of stuff but it's having the
commitment to be like i'm going to learn
this now i'm going to spend time
learning this skill which i don't ever
know if i'm getting a you know gonna be
able to use this in my life right oh
again what's a skill that's useful
actually why did you learn how to solve
a rubik's cube
because i've always just wanted to
because again you know imagine you're
the only asian kid in a white school
right so you're just like given these
like insane expectations to do these
like crazy skills right like people
people never believed me in school when
they said that i couldn't play chess
just because they're like but you're
you're the asian kid you're the smart
kid you should know how to do all these
things like you can't play shogi you
can't play go i'm like no it's like what
vacation
and so and rubik's cubes of it like
stereotypically right
yeah back when i was in school yeah by
the way welcome to trash chase we just
we just jumped right into it
yeah i'm connor featuring the boys
yeah the ruby skew player the rubik's
cube
and like i always like because it was
one of those things that i feel you go
to like any house right and there's like
a high possibility that it's just kind
of like sitting there as like an
ornament yeah right i was like very i'd
say like
out of 10 houses that have a rubik's
cube nine of them probably have like a
thin layer of dust on top of it because
it's just like oh it's just like a cool
little knick-knack to put on the shelf
right so yeah to make my it's like that
it's like that coffee table book you
know that like no one actually reads
when it's like oh you read this and
they're like yeah it's like iconic yeah
i don't know it's like a piece is it but
like
how often do you get to flex your
rubik's cube skills if it's not like if
i really interested if we didn't have
like a trash taste rubik's cube
how many times in your life has have
like you gone to a party and you're like
oh my god it's a rubik's cube guys
i'm about to flex step back step back
here comes the asian kid
i think everyone who knows how to solve
rubik's cube yeah um
says they don't regret it no no they
don't
actually very likely it's like weirdly
an impressive skill to have i i i
promised in a video i was going to learn
it it's not that hard i actually learned
it once as well because
i learned it i've completely forgotten
it but i remember like being that easy
though yeah it's not that hard i forgot
it i mean i i learned it in a day
yeah yeah because like i remember i was
in a hotel room um and i was staying in
this hotel and for some reason it was
like this you know it was like this chic
hotel they tried doing like different
things for their decorations and it just
had a rubik's cube that was unsolved in
this like really clean hotel right right
and my like ocd mine was just like
like how dare they it's hard perfect
like it's it's like they [ __ ]
designed this room to be like just
mildly infuriating just just
like it was a perfectly clean room it
looked amazing but on the desk there was
just a rubik's cube on there it's like
those memes of like you should see a
picture and it's like what's wrong with
this
yeah yeah yeah right and like i could
not sleep in this like hotel room
knowing that there was like i was just
like i was staring all night at this
rubik's cube that was just unsolved yeah
and so i just took a day where i just
googled how to solve a rubik's cube so i
could [ __ ] just
like i solve it before i went to bed
learn how to do it and they like i i
never really thought about how to solve
a rubik's cube before and i was like oh
it's actually pretty simple it's just an
algorithm basically yeah right it's just
it's just a bunch of like algorithms
you know when you're following a guide
it's pretty easy but the hard part is
being able to do it independently yeah
yeah so i never got to the point where
it was just like muscle memory you know
i was just like
it was just like you know it's a slow
process but anyone's able to solve a
rubik's cube i also remember like the
the reason why i actually like finally
learned how to solve it because i always
wanted to solve it since i was in high
school because again i got you know
called that kid but then you know
pandemic hit
everyone's stuck inside and it's like
you know i think everyone had that point
where it's like well i need to [ __ ]
do something right i can only place so
many hours of animal crossing per day
right yeah like sourdough bread
exactly exactly so i was like all right
well let's like learn a bunch of useless
skills so i think i learned how to do
like four or five different useless
skills and rubik's cubes just happened
to be one of the
other ones uh the other one was um you
know you've probably seen it before do
you know what kendama is
it's like this very old japanese toy
that it kind of looks like a hammer with
a ball oh that one yeah yeah yeah yeah i
did that as a kid but i wasn't very good
at it
what is that like it's just like it's
this like really ancient japanese toy uh
kind of like you know like spinning tops
yeah yeah it's like that yeah what's the
challenge the challenge is you have to
so there's three different plates on
this like it looks like a hammer yeah
and there's like a concave like plate on
the bottom and there's two concave
plates on the side and there's like a
little spike on the top yeah yeah yeah
uh the the regular one yeah
the regular one is like you kind of turn
it to the side and you have to
throw the ball up without actually
holding the ball and let it land in the
cup
yeah that's just like the simple skull
but there's like
a million different like tricks you can
do it's kind of like yo-yoing
right where it's like you can just like
regularly do a yo-yo and then there are
yo-yo tricks right which are just like
on another
level of difficulty and skill
and so like kendama is kind of the same
thing so like japan every year has like
these like kendama championships
where like you can actually get like
licenses
and like certificates to say that you're
a pro kendama like player if you do like
these certain tricks right that's cool
and one of the tricks i i could do like
the regular cop right because like
that's [ __ ] easy like anyone can do
that honestly one of the hardest ones is
where you have to
get it so that the ball lands on the
spike right by doing this and that
sounds impossible uh there's a trick to
it but then i was like i'm gonna learn
how to do that during this pandemic yeah
so i bought like a like a proper like
professional graded like kendama because
they have those there's like the toy
ones and there's no graded yeah there's
like a there's like a kendama
seriously there's like a national
kendama committee in japan where they're
like they look at each kingdom and
they're like yeah you can use that in
those in competitions and it comes with
like a certificate to be like yeah this
is a certified kendall so did you learn
how to do it yeah learn how to do it
and now you got to bring it into the
office i'm like curious now
you can't say that
there better be a video on screen right
now i'm joey dude how have you never
like posted a video on twitter or
something because it's like the most
niche thing on the planet i would like
to see it oh yeah you just randomly like
in the next anime man or joey video yeah
just you just like have i'm just gonna
have like just casually do it just don't
explain yourself you just casually do it
i swear to god i swear to god every
comment is going to be about that one
thing right
i i was uh gifted a rubik's cube once as
a kid yeah um for christmas by my
parents oh okay but it was a harry
potter rubik's cube okay
so all the tiles were themed they were
all pictures of harry potter yeah i
loved harry potter of course because i'm
british yeah
and so i have this cube right and i'm
thinking wow this is just this is just
great yeah and i i i turn it once so oh
no i'll put it back
i don't want to ruin it i don't know i
like the picture yeah what's the point
in the cube
[Music]
and then one time i i i gave you a few
days later or whatever i i love this
cube
it's the most awful thing like it's so
hard to solve because the pictures are
so [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah so i start
turning in i turn like four or five
times and i'm like okay i'm gonna start
turning it back
and then i turn it back i'm like one
okay
oh [ __ ] it's not back the way it was
yeah and then i'm like okay i think it's
like just one there's one thing out of
play i i can fix this
i start trying things and i just keep
[ __ ] it up just gets worse and worse
and then i realized what a [ __ ] toy this
is i i'm like eight years old i cannot
solve this now i'm just [ __ ]
and now if i want to see the picture of
harry potter i have to actually like
learn how to solve it yeah and i don't
know how no one's even began to explain
to me right algorithm i don't know that
i google i i get one hour a day to go
online i'm not using that i'm gonna go
watch yu-gi-oh gx episode 400 part one
of three yeah
i'm gonna do that no look at the ruby's
cube so i yeah yeah i i was just like
really disappointed i was really sad and
um i remember i found it a few years
later and i
i thought i'll i'll give it a shot i
just couldn't do it
that seems more difficult than a regular
one it wasn't yeah the pictures were all
like like
harry potter and his hogwarts are they
all like did you they were like brown
did you take like the stickers off yeah
okay okay
that's what i did as a kid but then when
i did that it wasn't you know because it
was this is the factory yeah factory
production all the excuses were perfect
so when i started peeling them and [ __ ]
they were all like a little bit wonky
yeah
stickers are some of the most annoying
[ __ ] to like place yeah because you put
it and you're like i'm doing it
perfectly flat flat you put it on douche
i don't know how that happens every time
building a gun plug you like yeah right
yeah yeah exactly you're like
it's like bad but
yeah right
yeah i mean like i think
the only like useless skill i've learned
before was i i mean do you guys know how
to juggle
i i learned how to do the one-handed you
learn how to use the one-handed yeah but
like you know with two balls we kind of
like oh yeah yeah yeah i never i never
got to the point where i was with three
yeah i mean growing up in brighton beach
i remember like one day i just decided
to just learn how to juggle using
pebbles and stuff yeah and i think i can
still juggle i don't know i don't know i
don't know it's been a while we have to
have a video where we show each other
the useless skills actually the most
useful party trick dude you guys have
any party tricks that you that you like
can show off in a party or whatever not
that i don't know what i remember okay
i'm like [ __ ] susan boyle every party
i go to just everyone stops
actually like the most useless uh the
most useful party trick i know is just
being able to open a bottle with
anything yeah like i've done that a few
times because it's not just like it's
every time you do it if you wanna if you
wanna just know a trick that will take
you five minutes to learn but will be
useful in basically every party you go
to yeah just learn how to open a bottle
with a lighter or another box i feel
like us not showing these abilities is
like making this episode worse
no one no one believes
us filming this like how often do you go
to a party and you see a rubik's cube
there you're like finally my boys
boys my time to shine uh i can click my
wrists on command
that doesn't sound healthy
oh
you got you got like uh eight-year-old
wrist
is that the gamer wrist
scars
tell me you have carpal tunnel without
saying your carpal tunnel i don't know i
can just click both of them yeah i only
know like small little things that will
you know maybe impress like
your five-year-old cousin yeah you know
when you're at a home like i can do like
the water droplet sound like that's the
only thing like oh yeah that's skype
you can do the skype thing perfectly the
skype thing skype
[Laughter]
that appeals to a very like tight knee
yeah like yeah yeah you had to be on the
internet in the mid 2000s to appreciate
that
the windows xp shut down noise
[Applause]
do that thing where you like hold your
body up i don't know why i've always
been able to do that uh what do you mean
oh the one was like like through here
like that like when you're just like on
a surface and you cannot hold your whole
body oh you mean like what breakdancers
do kind of like yeah i've always been
able to do that i don't know but yeah
you have to have like good core strength
for that don't you
i guess you've got slightly i guess like
you've got great core strength right i
don't know maybe i do i don't know